good morning Hank it is Friday December
17 2010 time for the project for the
awesome is that too much felt like a lot
I think I actually hurt my shoulder
today is the day that YouTube is not
about kittens who are inspired by
kittens but about charity you can
participate in the project for awesome
all day and all day tomorrow by going to
youtube.com slash p4a or project for
awesome com all day long a huge army of
commenters including Hank and me will be
running around going to every project
for awesome video we can find and
commenting on it like crazy and rating
and favoriting and this year there is
added incentive nerdfighters you may
know how much I hate pennies well this
year Hank and I will be donating one
penny for every project for awesome
comment up to 1 million comments this
year our pennies will go to benefit Save
the Children and Partners in Health two
charities that nerdfighteria has worked
with extensively before which I'm going
to tell you about in a second but first
I want to tell you a story so Hank a few
years ago just after the invasion of
Iraq I was watching the news with my
friend Hasan and they were showing this
very nice house that had been bombed and
there was a huge hole in the wall that
had been covered over with plywood and
on that plywood there was all this
Arabic graffiti and black spray-paint
and the news guy was talking about the
anger on the Arab Street and everything
and then Hassan starts laughing I said
what's so funny he said the graffiti
I said what's funny about it he said it
says happy birthday sir despite the
circumstances Hank the news man and I
had fallen into the same trap we both
assumed it was political angry violent
graffiti not happy birthday sir despite
the circumstances graffiti and ever
since I've been thinking about why we
fell into that trap as humans we have a
bad habit of imagining people who live
far away from us or in different
circumstances from us as fundamentally
other but in nerdfighteria we've already
learned that people who live in very
different circumstances from us are not
fundamentally other we know it because
we've seen what happens when we work
with Save the Children and Shawn's
uncultured project to build a pond sand
filter in Bangladesh that after two
years is still providing clean water to
all these people and we know it because
with the help of the Harry Potter
Alliance and Partners in Health we were
able to fly the SS dftba full of
life-saving supplies to haiti we've
already seen what happens when you stop
seeing people in poverty as other and
start seeing them as part of us you know
us people who do this to remind
themselves to be awesome us people who
even in the wake of terrible tragedy
find a way to happy dance we want to
keep that awesome going not only because
it helps people who live in poverty but
also because it helps us it reminds us
that when we look at graffiti that we
don't understand it very
well say happy birthday sir despite the
circumstances so every project for
awesome comment up to a million comments
is worth one penny to Partners in Health
or Save the Children and if you go to
projectforawesome.com right now you'll
find lots of amazing ways to donate to
great organizations we've got raffle
prizes from Mika kitty and wheezy waiter
and nerimon and ryan higa and tons of
other youtubers and lots of awesome
nerdfighter raffles including the chance
to win my nerd glasses and the last
remaining bottle jon also everyone who
enters my zombie apocalypse novella
raffle will be emailed the story and one
lucky winner will receive the actual
printed version of the story extensively
annotated by me and signed for the
winner but in my opinion the best raffle
is the one where if you win your name
will be the name of Hanks new album like
if the winner of the raffles name is
Jeff Hanks new album will be called Jeff
I'm gonna enter that one like 400 times
so please go over to
projectforawesome.com to donate and join
us all day today and tomorrow at
youtube.com slash p4a to comment and
rate and favorite as many awesome p4a
videos as possible commenting army i
will see you at youtube.com slash p4a
all day and night where Hank and I will
be constantly uploading videos Old Spice
guy style and made a fourth project for
awesome be the best one yet nerdfighters
thank you so much for all your p4a
videos thank you for inspiring us hank
dftba by the way if you haven't
subscribed to youtube.com slash p4a
you're not gonna have any fun today I
made a rhyme oh you're my friend
is gonna be weird if we kiss just some
beautiful though it's wrong